so my parents have actually recently
been traveling in Peru they've been
hiking from Lima all the way to Machu
Picchu and along the way they're eating
a lot of amazing foods and they're
sending me all these pictures of amazing
Peruvian food so I thought why not make
Peruvian food today hey what's up guys
welcome back to another cooking video
today I am craving Lomo saltado Lomo
saltado is a Peruvian dish that I
absolutely love it has some sort of meat
today we'll be using beef but you can
use chicken pork whatever you want it's
also stir-fried with some tomatoes
onions and most importantly some french
fries now ever since I had Lomo saltado
for the first time I've been obsessed
with it just because when I first ate it
I tasted something I was very familiar
to me
it tasted like Chinese food Cantonese
food to be specific now growing up in a
Cantonese household we eating stir-fry
all the time so when I first had my
Peruvian dining experience I was blown
away by the fact that they used blocks
and they severe fry a lot of food so
back in the 1800s Peru is a very popular
destination for Chinese immigrants
Nalani Chinese immigrants once they were
in Peru would want to try and recreate
Chinese food but obviously didn't have
Chinese ingredients in Peru they had
Peruvian ingredients and that is where
the Chinese Peruvian cuisine came to be
the term Chifa actually stems from the
singing in Chinese sick fan which means
to eat or eat rice all right to get
start over there Lomo saltado
we're using beef today I have a 1 pound
sirloin steak that I'm gonna cut up into
strips I have 3 tomatoes at the red
onion I have a jalapeno I'm only using a
jalapeno because I don't have access to
the aji amarillo pepper that is very
popular in Peru which is the pepper they
use for a lot of their foods so I've
always used jalapeno or serrano as a
substitute we have some aromatics we're
gonna use in garlic and some ginger some
spices cumin black pepper white pepper
salt soy sauce and white vinegar so
before we begin with the meat we're
gonna start with the French fries just
because I'm using store-bought french
fries so for this part just follow the
packaging instructions and we'll see
these french fries at the end
our cooking process alright so first we
are going to start with our state I'm
gonna cut them into tiny little pieces
into strips because we're gonna be
rigging wedges with our Tomatoes and
with your onions
so we're basically replicating that same
shape with strips of steak
all right here we go all right so we're
gonna put our state into a bowl alright
so we got our steak I'm going to pull
out an ingredient and I didn't cover in
the ingredients that I just did cover
sesame oil just to give it a little bit
of a binder for all the spices I'm about
to put in here so we got white pepper
black pepper I like the combination of
white and black pepper I don't know why
salt and cumin and I love using my hands
to mix we're gonna set this aside to
marinate on its own on to our veggies or
our produce get our tomatoes alright so
we're just gonna cut up our tomatoes
into wedges
now you can also take out the seeds and
the center of the tomato if you don't
want your Lomo saltado too runny it does
produce a pretty runny gravy if you
leave the seeds in which I liked
cuz I like mixing it in with the rice
tomato set aside and now onion time and
the same thing we're gonna cut it into
wedges
oh geez it was kind of onions me oh man
pretty got me alright last but not least
we got our jalapeno before we actually
start our frying we're gonna get our
aromatics prepped like always
ginger and garlic since chief of cuisine
has its roots in Cantonese cooking why
not stick close to the og methods I
don't know any Cantonese dish that
doesn't start with ginger and garlic
alright so finally we got everything
prepped honestly the longest part of
this whole process is the prep but once
we start cooking
there's a stir-fry it's gonna be super
fast all right here we go stir-fry on
time I start with a little bit of oil
here a little bit more
now a stir-fry you always always always
want to have the highest heat possible
because we're basically two slash
cooking everything so we're going to
start with the aromatics first ginger
and the garlic you're gonna want to
saute the garlic and the ginger for
about a minute just infuse the flavor of
garlic and ginger into the oil and next
we're gonna toss in our beef we're gonna
want to saute this for about two to
three minutes just enough to Brown them
but we're not gonna cook it all the way
through because this will be a two-step
process we're going to throw the beef
back into the wok after we've
incorporated the tomatoes and the onions
and now we can also take out the garlic
and ginger because you only needed them
for the flavors and so go ahead and
discard the garlic and ginger now that
we have all these beautiful flavor
inside the wok we're tossing the onions
and we're gonna saute them for about two
to three minutes until they start to
turn soft and translucent
next drum the jalapenos and the tomatoes
and we're gonna sauté these for another
minute then just as the tomatoes are
starting to turn soft we're gonna throw
the stake back in and finish the cooking
process once we have all the ingredients
put together here go ahead and turn off
the heat and let's get back to the
french fries and all we have to do is
dump those in and toss them around and
once you've worked the crispy fries into
the sauces it is time to plate we've got
our Lomo saltado we're gonna serve it
with some brown rice restaurant style
restaurants always do that
so the bowl trick is some saltado in
here and let's go ahead and dress it up
with some green onions
and some cilantro just gets the plate in
just a nice pop of green there we go
[Music]
feel free to give it a try at home and
if you do trying to make this at home
make sure to post it tag me
DME whatever because I always want to
check out everyone's take on what I do
this is my tank send me yours and I hope
you guys enjoy the most love tato over
cooking tomatoes a little bit too long
okay and we're still taste it
[Music]